[Music]
before the flash gives bail to hide in
an alternate timeline and the whole DCU
starts to stink like a dead fish catch
one of the last installments before the
whole universe gets James Gunn down in
its prime as long as long as I still
breathe the Dome still stands okay pass
its prime I bring a warning from Beyond
your realm okay way past its prime
Shazam exclamation point Fury of the
Gods with the director returning for
what he hopes is the last time comes the
long-awaited sequel to Shazam
exclamation point that follows up the
Charming original with two plus hours of
high fructose Cape slaw
we're all the best drama went down off
camera as the Rocks attempt to be DC's
hierarchy of power broker backfired so
hard it tanked two films the desire to
succeed
will never be as powerful as having the
guts to fail and gave Zach Levi a mental
breakdown because he couldn't put
Hawkman in the credits or whatever we
had a awesome scene that would have tied
me in to the JSA with Hawkman and with
cyclone and we were thwarted resulting
in three films where the closest thing
we'll get to Shazam versus Black Adam is
the actors dueling vitamin Brands flow
supplements versus Zoe energy whose
pills will you swallow since we last saw
him Billy Batson turned movie 17. now
even his t-shirts are too old to still
be living at home with six minutes of
total screen time Asher Angel acts like
a kid with a nine to five and mouths to
feed all or none that's the rule I'm
calling an emergency meeting after
school I want you there well Zachary
acts like a youth pastor who just drank
his first soda if they just point that
stop at us we dodged
like dodgeball you take down this
Fury domey magic bowl thing what do you
even have a job Wonder Woman doesn't
have a job stop no no seriously do you
think she wears a ponytail in glasses
and like nobody recognizes her she's
like an accountant or something just
stop has anyone told these two they're
playing the same character yet have they
even met
they're not the only ones with
mismatched kid and supercells there's
like eight other people to keep track of
like Freddie Freeman who Powers up from
standard everyday teenage horny to a new
super horny form You're Gonna Want to
Hold On Tight
Mary who's aged out of the getting a new
actor to play her Shazam self either
that or DC saw the old actress post
about January 6th Plus Eugene and Pedro
who were granted the minimum legal
amount of character development thanks
to a new California state program
where's your team where he always is
mapping out the room of doors I'm gay
yeah we know but oh great job you two
and Darla a part-time character in a
movie and full-time Skittle spokesperson
why were there Skittles in my pockets it
was supposed to be a surprise
good isn't it
three goddesses come to Earth to punish
Humanity refashion their dad's broken
staff put a bubble around Philadelphia
and also find the seed of life in an
effort to restore their realm and also
destroy Earth okay screw all that win
three goddesses come to Earth to get
body slammed into hospice care
stop let me go to the underworld in
peace peace look all kinds of stupid on
a dragon you think I will destroy you
and molest a disabled teenager I'm over
6 000 years old
the shazamilee will bravely fly into
action and get bounced around like
Technicolor beach balls because it turns
out super fights are super boring when
everyone has God mode turned on and the
villain's magic just doesn't work on the
hero for reasons
possible
watch these Hometown Heroes dig deep and
save Philadelphia a city that will cram
their mouths full of horse poop and
appreciation but aside from its original
setting well for superhero movies at
least Frank give me the gun we're in a
hurry come on where is it it's in your
hand wait wait
strap in for two hours of the same
tropes Marvel and DC have been leaning
on for decades like pointing out
superheroes have silly names I'm Freddie
Freeman Captain every Power the
Philadelphia Fiasco thundercracks
Shazam it's maximum voltage actually
amongst other names we're still kind of
workshopping itself going out to the
audience the crazy thing that just
happened how are you actually sisters
because the age difference is very
noticeable and slightly upsetting it's
only so many mentors I can run over with
this man
did I just save you while you were
listening to this song destroying a
professional sports Stadium
Cameo is only the most hopeless nerd
would recognize
cameos you kind of recognize from that
other thing you're the best Captain
Marvel and cameos you definitely
recognize no matter how to place their
theme song sounds at a child's funeral
[Music]
so kick back for a superhero movie that
feels like it was written by Chad GPT
that proves superhero films Aren't Dead
per se but shows that when you have
nothing new to add just make a fast and
furious joke and be done with it at
least that's what we do when we're out
of ideas because I've seen all of the
Fast and Furious movies Lady it's all
about family
so who plays Queenie Shaw in the DC
Universe or Luke Hobbs are they excited
for Aquaman to being the next one did
they like Wonder Woman in Fast Five does
he recognize the wizard from fast seven
what about Peacemaker and fast nine do
they know black Superman is in the
suicide squad ooh what about Michael
Rooker
story
please clap how do you do fellow kids
Aaron Taylor Johnson the ironist the
Wizard of yes Rachel Helen of Ploy Lucy
in the Sky with demons big quilly style
waiting for a Godot and when you tell
someone with a joker Abby that the
snyderburst is dead
oh
Teen Titans no
what's happening to all the people
inside these Office Buildings
would I rather be feared or loved easy
both I want people to be afraid of how
much they love me those cannibals are
onto something I taste delicious peaches
peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches